bitcoin's on blast for the first time
since April of 2022 it zoomed past the
45,000 Mark today and came within 78
bucks of 46,000 before retreating but
we're still above 45,000 at 45,1 186
right now after being crowned the best
performing asset class of 2023 bitcoin's
prowess continues into the new year
boosted in great part by Wall Street
speculation the cities and Exchange
Commission is within days like three
days of approving at least one of the 13
spot Bitcoin ETF applications but what
then happens to the price of Bitcoin
once we do see an approval let's bring
in one of bitcoin's biggest bulls and an
early investor in the crypto space pomp
Investments Anthony pomp leano all right
so here here's what we're hearing and
here's what you predicted just a couple
of months ago on the claim and countdown
you said said it would be a a bunch of
them yes and let them all fight it out
Charlie gasparino sources saying Kathy
would of Arc Investments because her
application was officially done first uh
my sources were telling me Black Rock
gbtc and Kathy Wood all right who's it
gonna be has have you changed your
opinion at all I I don't know exactly
who's going to go first what I think
they should do is they should approve
everyone right if you're going to allow
the free market to make decisions in
this country then we shouldn't have
Regulators picking winners and losers we
don't need kingmaker just approve
everyone let them go fight it out now
what's interesting is there's estimated
between 50 billion and hundred billion
dollar of assets that are going to go
into these ETFs over the coming years
which means that the fee Revenue every
year could be 500 million to a billion
dollars and so if you do that that's 500
million to a billion dollars every
single year how much money would you
spend now to get those assets and have
them be sticky we are probably going to
see hundreds of millions of dollars
spent on marketing in the next 12 to 18
months by these Wall Street
organizations saying if you want to buy
a spot Bitcoin ETF come buy it with me
me and not my competitors and I think
that is just something that we haven't
seen in finance it's going to be the
greatest marketing Blitz ever would you
invest in a piece of the ETF or would
you invest in Black Rock stock or Arc or
perhaps gbtc well gbtc is going to
convert up just you know one for one
there so B Bitcoin has been an
incredible asset it's highly volatile it
goes up and it goes down a lot but if
you look over a long period of time it
continues to go up and you know if you
really think about it from a
generational trade there's every single
generation has kind of one trade or one
investment idea that tends to be the big
winner and I think that this generation
has woken up to the idea that we have to
debase the currency we are going to
continue to do that for decades to come
and so you're going to get into hard
assets Bitcoin historically has been the
big winner there it's up 170% last year
I think people believe it's going to go
up a lot more in 2024 and Beyond but but
let me just you had just said that
marketing and fees will bring huge
windfalls to the arcs and the black
rocks of the world yes so why take your
shot with something that's vol as
Bitcoin and instead why not go into
black rock stock or so you're saying no
don't do the arc stock and don't do the
people are still going to do that stuff
I just think Bitcoin has outperformed
those stocks historically and I think
it'll continue to do for a long period
of time one thing people should remember
is that when you buy the ETF you buying
exposure to bitcoin you're not actually
buying Bitcoin itself and so then there
gets into the constituency some people
say no I want to own Bitcoin itself I
want to hold my private Keys want to
have that self- custody but for a lot of
people they're not going to go sign up
for a coinbase account they're not going
to go figure out how to buy Bitcoin
directly and so this etf's right in the
brokerage account they're going to go
and they're going to allocate well it
opens the market to millions of retail
investors who don't want to have to
remember a 90 digigit password or
something and then you lose it and it's
a nightmare with that in mind what is
your price target for Bitcoin in 20124
from low to high I I don't know exactly
where it's going to go in the short term
when the ETF gets approved there
definitely is going to be a drastic
increase uh what I do not think is going
to happen is it would it's very hard for
me to see that we get a new all-time
high just off of the ETF alone what I do
think is going to happen though is that
we're going to get the Bitcoin having uh
at the uh beginning of Q2 we're also
going to get interest rate cuts and
we're probably going to get quantitative
easing in 2024 as well and so what
you're going to have is you're gonna
have a dep a demand shock and a supply
shock meaning that there's gonna be more
demand for Bitcoin at the same time that
having is going to occur we're gonna go
from 900 Bitcoin coming into the market
every day down to 450 and so that is
really going to drive the price I do
think we get a new all-time high in
20124 but it's the uh combination of all
of these things not just the ETF alone
for people who don't know the Havoc is
written into the original code of
Bitcoin and it chops it in half every
five years am I correct every four years
every four years okay so 2023 was
actually let's broaden this discussion
to the the ugly underbelly of what
happened in crypto and that was of
course what actually started in November
of 2022 and that was the the the failure
of Sam bakman Freed's crypto exchange
and I mean that was just a disaster
obviously uh FTX was a bad bad thing for
and that triggered a real selloff in
Bitcoin but where do we go from here
because he's been convicted yes and he
will serve most likely a somewhat
lengthy we don't know how long but a
lengthy prison sentence because it's
Federal and they have guidelines and
then you've got CZ who also had binance
he ran binance and he has faced all
kinds of charges are we done with that
nonsense or is it just like the old
saying that there's a sucker born every
minute and you're going to definitely
see people try and take advantage of
that bad people do bad things regardless
of the industry you know one of the
things that's really interesting is uh
if you look at FTX FTX basically took
customer money they went and they
invested it and they lost it right and
uh there's a whole bunch of questions as
to why they did it how they did it uh
but the big thing was they didn't tell
customers they were going to do it right
that that's ultimately what the big
issue was if you remember also in 2023
we hit Banks who took customers money
and they went they bought treasuries
those treasuries went underwater right
now the difference is the bank said
we're going to take your money we're
going to go and do this so there's
disclosures there's regulation there's
all these different things but we had
Banks fail and we had crypto exchanges
fail and they fail for different reasons
but ultimately I think what the average
person is going to start to figure out
is I need to pay attention I need to
know where am I putting my money the
days of simply just putting your money
in an organization and hoping that it's
still there years from now is gone and
so I think that the internet has really
opened people's eyes and they're
starting to understand what is FDIC
Insurance how do I actually protect this
stuff and I think that Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency for this generation again
bit was born in the ashes of the global
financial crisis and we now are seeing
the capitulation of Wall Street where
they are saying we have to get in the
game and yet the big Banks the Legacy
Banks appear to be part of writing the
digital asset anti-money laundering act
the new regulations what rule if any
should the big Legacy Banks and we know
that Jamie Diamond absolutely hates
Bitcoin he calls it fraud yeah I know
what a shock to you JP Morgan is doing
stuff in uh in he he's made a very very
clear he doesn't like it but what role
if any should should the Legacy banks
have in writing the regulation that
would deal with crypto well I I think
that obviously anytime you have the
market participants writing the
regulation uh there's a lot of questions
right I for a long time I've always
thought that if you're a politician and
you get put into office by donations
from a certain industry you shouldn't be
able to regulate over that industry amen
right amen and so having the banks right
the banking regulation it's just
regulatory capture but the difference
here what I think is really important
for people to understand is Bitcoin is a
decentralized organization there is no
CEO there's no board of directors you
can write whatever rules you want it is
a decentralized protocol and so your
regulatory capture does not work against
something that now has been deemed not a
security and has been adopted by
hundreds of millions of people around
the world so you may be able to capture
the market and other parts of Finance
but Bitcoin is going to remain resilient
against those regulatory capture
initiatives HP we've got lobbyists from
the farm industry and big oil on the
phone for you you're not real happy but
I'm with you I think that that I love
everyone colors judgment for sure PP is
great to see you happy New Year much